open the door get out the car
u.s army officer karen nozzario was
driving on a dark road in rural virginia
last december
when police pulled him over for a
missing license plate
what happened next he and his attorney
say was a case of racial profiling
and police brutality my hands are right
here what's going on
i'm honestly afraid can i yeah
you should be get out windsor virginia
police
officer joe gutierrez pepper sprayed
lieutenant nazario
even though his hands were raised and he
was not resisting
get out of the car don't reach in there
my hands are out please
please look this is really messed up
my dog is in the back my dog is choking
right get out of the car
nazario repeatedly asked the policeman
why he was being assaulted
get out of the car right now this is not
how you treat a vet uh
i'm actively serving this country and
this is how you're gonna treat me
i didn't do anything the policeman
ordered nazario who was
unarmed and wearing his military uniform
out of the car and knocked him to the
ground
why am i being treated like this why are
you not cooperating get on the ground
why am i being treated like this rosario
has sued the windsor police for
violating his constitutional rights
alleging assault and illegal detention
he was not in any way his hands are
clearly visible
and he is the one that remains calm when
these men are threatening this one
it's absurd rosario who was not charged
in the incident says the policeman
threatened to damage his reputation in
the military
if he told anyone about how he was
treated they knew they were in the wrong
and then they threatened to destroy a
man's career if he called him out on it
rosario had temporary license plates
displayed
on his vehicle virginia's governor has
ordered
an independent investigation the windsor
police department has not responded to
news media requests for comment
officials from the town of windsor
virginia say gutierrez
has been fired rob reynolds al jazeera